you should do it
no
it is
we don't even need to we don't even need
to question Cheap Trick
[Music]
hi there I'm Andy Circus who uh Andy
Circus and have you Idris Elba helps
yeah and we are here to do first
impressions first impression they count
by the way always here we go all right
ready yes that is not a onion
you're an onion that's not an onion like
okay oh
all right
who is it
it is I am you you think I am what I am
and I am
knobby yes Dobby not knobby no it was
your direction that's it it was terrible
I told you I'm rubbishing this morning
oh
come on
foreign
Dracula um I do it again
Jurassic Park yeah
come on it was actually a dinosaur that
was really good that was a T-Rex T-Rex
Victorious T-Rex wives because of the
way up yeah yeah yeah
hey man I guess he's coming a little bit
like that he kind of uh well I got a
kind of curly hair
uh comedian no yes bro yeah I mean yeah
very popular very popular show
anyone
no we're all drawing a blank Bart
Simpson
Bart Simpson I know
you would you should do it
no
no it is
we don't even need to we don't even need
to question Cheap Trick sorry
okay
um okay
what do you think cauliflower thank you
oh that wasn't too bad that's very good
actually I got it straight away
thingies here
a wrap
sing a dance a act a DJ
yes
[Laughter]
that's the worst impression of myself
that I've ever seen that's brilliant
actually oh no where is it where is the
yourself code
well I mean I suppose if I was gonna you
know like really do a version of me I
mean I I climb I play the saxophone I uh
you know you're not you're not even
giving yourself because you're very
scary am I yeah
you're very late all right guys we're
all a bit scared about the circus just a
little bit man but wow it's just creepy
characters and yeah that's that's my you
know and it's amazing how you can turn
into like animals and stuff well you
look back at your kid really I mean I've
been
called an animal
okay here we go
very good Elvis Presley oh that was good
come on that was calm oh my God now no
I'm gonna go again just to shake it up a
little bit for the
factors come on we'll do it again don't
worry don't worry about that don't worry
you can cut that out right oh it says
lad Bible they wanted to see that so
I'll take from your party from mine okay
right
voila
Wallace Gromit
is that a plug
oh he didn't do one yeah no no does
anyone know in the crew who that was
rhymes with James Dean
Mr Wayne yes
was that not very good that was actually
that was actually brilliant now now I
know who it's supposed to be I I get it
Allen
okay
my name is Max
Aurelius Maximus
um my guy Russell Crowe exactly it's
very good
ah
I said no and this is going to be
terrible
well because you know we've been doing
and we was like in abandon now we were
just like um Paul McCartney yeah
okay
in there Paul I'm really sorry about
that impression of you
um
actually this is gonna be really quite
difficult to do but
um I I I
okay so I'm
very fast thinking I remember I'm I'm
actually
um but I've got a brain that works like
like a razor and um and
um
[Laughter]
because he's incredibly articulate
actually and then speaks with the word
uh he's sort of actually more probably
down here if I actually really thinking
it's terribly well-known actor and uh
loved it rhymes with uh Brana no no it
runs with
um
Cabbage Patch
the Benedict
oh it was that shade there's a shade
Benedict is a phenomenal actor he's
amazing he's incredible okay I can't
even do this one
I can do a character that he played but
I can't do him I don't know
um okay
I've been here
hell
tell
um uh okay let me see if I can do it
again
how you doing man yeah no oh no no
listen when I'm rolling around in Judo I
just oh this time
I was meant to be Bane you're all right
no that's actually a really good
uh well how do you feel being the winner
of this extraordinary I mean Impressions
is not my thing I'm not very good at you
know it is your thing I'm not very
excited to take up a new as well as
being a rapper and all the other things
fantastic yeah okay another question
another string to my bow yeah absolutely
thank you very much
impression thank you thank you thank you
I don't even know who that is
[Laughter]
now I know how the poor people of
Pompeii felt like
um
Bing bamboo she got me there like the a
Express train